[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain a science fiction drama film
called another earth spoilers ahead
watch out and take care
[Music]
the movie begins with a high school
party rhoda williams a 17 year old girl
is a highly intelligent student who has
just gotten into mit she celebrates with
her boyfriend in the background she
narrates that she fell in love with
space science after seeing jupiter's
rapid succession in one of nasa's voyage
pictures rhoda feels like she can do
anything in the world later at night she
drives intoxicated while listening to
the radio which says that a new planet
with its own moon identical to earth has
appeared in the solar system scientists
are baffled by the planet as no one saw
it coming the radio asks the viewers to
look to the north to see the planet
which is clearly visible from earth an
intoxicated rhoda looks outside the
window of her car as she drives it at
high speed
somewhere near a family of three is in a
car parked beside the road the kid names
his robot bob and the parents laugh with
him as they talk we get to know that the
mother is pregnant their conversation is
cut short when rota's car hits them
causing a terrible accident she is
injured but conscious she steps out of
her car and goes to the other car to see
the couple unconscious not knowing what
to do she turns around and is horrified
when she sees the little boy lying
lifelessly on the ground police sirens
wail in the distance and the screen goes
black showing us the newly found planet
in the distance a clip of rhoda in a
cell is shown she has been arrested
after the event it is now four years
later a news report tells us that earth
2 is now way closer to the earth and
seems to be an exact replica of the
earth by its appearance it is now easily
visible from earth's surface the
structure of its continents and ocean
even its cities and towns as seen from
the telescope seems to be identical to
the earth's scientists have tried
sending radio signals to the planet and
received a signal back however they have
not been able to decipher it some
scientists don't even believe that the
planet exists and believe it to be a
cosmic mirror that is reflecting the
image of the earth itself
four years after the accident rhoda gets
out of prison she goes out for the first
time and her parents come to pick her up
while talking about the second planet
her brother mentions an essay contest
sponsored by millionaire entrepreneur
keith harding who is funding the very
first space flight to earth 2. he is
granting a free ticket to the civilian
who has the best motivation to join
rhoda comes back home and looks at her
belongings in her room she doesn't feel
like the person she used to be and
doesn't like the room anymore she looks
outside the window and is fascinated to
see the second earth in the sky rhoda
then gets on her laptop and learns about
the united space ventures the program
that her brother talked about earlier to
win the civilian ticket she has to write
an essay about the reason for wanting to
go there and submit it she stares at the
laptop but doesn't type anything then
she takes all her necessary belongings
to the house's attic and declares it her
new room she sleeps on a mattress and
pastes a picture of the night sky on the
wall for decoration the following day
rhoda goes to an employment office to
look for a job being an ex-convict she
cannot go to mit anymore and other
colleges won't take her the lady at the
office offers her a job according to her
qualifications but rhoda insists on
getting a job that doesn't require her
to talk to anyone she gets a job as a
janitor at her old high school she
starts working as a janitor the next day
and doesn't seem to hate her job it has
been exactly four years since the
accident rhoda goes to the intersection
where the fatal incident took place and
looks around just then a car stops
nearby and a man comes out of it rhoda
remembers the guy being the man she saw
inside the other car she is surprised
because she thought she had killed them
all the man keeps a robot toy in the
pole nearby in the memory of his son and
drives away rhoda quickly rushes home
and looks up the case on her laptop it
turns out the man's name is john
burroughs both his wife and son died in
the car accident but he had gone into a
coma a few years later he woke up and
has been living alone ever since upon
further research she learns that he has
dropped out of his yale music faculty
position she writes down his address and
goes to meet him the next day not
knowing what to do she looks at him
drinking in his messy living room
through the window the night is snowy
and cold ridden by her guilt and seeing
jon in such a state rhoda is distressed
she walks on the snow slowly undressing
in the end she lies down shivering and
naked her fingers become blue from
hypothermia and she looks at earth 2 as
she lies in the cold the screen goes
black
in the following scene she lies on a
hospital bed someone had found her and
saved her from the cold her fingers are
injured but she doesn't have any fatal
injuries when she gets back home she
finally writes an essay to apply for the
ticket to visit earth 2. in the essay
she mentions that mad men outcasts
orphans have been subject to all the new
experiments in the past and not the
nobles of the society hence being a
felon she believes that she is the best
candidate for this kind of experiment
feeling great after submitting her essay
she goes to a grocery to get candies
where she meets her high school
boyfriend whom she was partying with
that night he tells her he has gotten
into business school and introduces her
to his girlfriend he acts strange and
awkward when rhoda tells him that she
works as a janitor feeling embarrassed
by where life has brought her she walks
out of the store without the candies
rhoda knows that she won't feel
satisfied until she has apologized to
jon so she goes to his house again she
knocks on the door but the nervousness
gets the best of her instead of telling
him she is the one who killed his family
she lies and pretends to be a maid sent
by maidenhaven cleaning services for a
free trial john who has been living in
the place without cleaning it for months
accepts the offer and lets her clean the
house rhoda is too deep into the lie so
she just goes with it she starts
cleaning and john notices her
investigating a telescope lying in one
of the rooms when she finishes john
unknown to her identity invites her next
week to clean the house again the week
passes and rhoda practices telling jon
the truth however when she knocks on his
door she is taken by nervousness again
so she cleans his house again and
doesn't say anything she begins going to
his place every week however jon hardly
ever talks to her one night rhoda and
her family watch a live broadcast of a
scientist trying to communicate with
someone on earth too she successfully
receives a signal of someone talking and
it turns out that the person talking on
the other end is the scientist herself
from the other planet she is her exact
copy in every aspect same name date and
location of birth even the occupation
and childhood memories match the whole
world watches in awe now everyone
believes that earth 2 is a mirror planet
with the same people the news baffles
rhoda and she comes out of her house to
look at the planet and its moon the news
has created a huge debate of what might
be true and what is a lie
physicists theorize that earth 2 is a
mere planet an exact copy of our earth
including all of its people some believe
that we could meet and talk with our
exact copy a person who may be identical
but has led a different life john and
rhoda share a common interest in space
science he offers rhoda to use his
telescope and she agrees the two then
play video games and seem to be
developing some kind of relationship
with each other jon offers rhoda a ride
home
days go by and john and rhoda get closer
one day they arrive on the subject of
the first expedition that plans to go to
earth 2. rhoda tells him about the essay
she has submitted but jon is skeptical
about the expedition he insists mankind
is not ready to accept the realization
that they are no longer unique since
they still believe that they are the
center of the universe john suddenly
gets agitated when he learns that rhoda
has washed a sweater that belongs to his
wife he angrily asks her to leave a
radio program that broadcasts a debate
warns about the potential dangers of
earth 2. some people believe that since
the people on earth 2 have similar
access to us in weapons and are of
suspicious nature there is a high
probability of a war occurring between
the planets rota comes home to john's
car parked by her home he is there to
apologize for his behavior earlier and
she forgives him then he insists she
come with him somewhere he takes her to
a university auditorium and gives her a
private concert of a new piece of music
using a saw the two feel a greater
connection to each other after the
performance they go back to jon's home
one thing leads to another and they end
up having sex later jon tells her about
the accident and his years-long coma but
rhoda still doesn't tell him the truth
when she returns home rhoda's brother
tells her that people from the space
flight have called she calls them back
and is surprised when the millionaire
keith harding picks up the phone he
tells her that she has won the essay
competition and has been selected to
voyage to earth 2. rhoda is over the
moon and goes to jon about the
achievement jon praises her at first but
then asks her not to go since they are
in a good relationship now he sees a
future with rhoda which scares her she
now knows that she cannot lie to him for
long she finally tells him that she was
the one who caused the accident that
night jon is speechless he simply sits
on the sofa and asks her to get out of
his house when she comes back home she
is bombarded by news reporters standing
in front of her house the news about her
getting the lucky ticket has spread
around and now people are digging up her
past and broadcasting the accident
luckily her father comes to the rescue
and brings her inside she receives a
ticket for her flight to earth 2 from
the united space ventures
a few days later rhoda hears a
scientist's theory in a telecast he says
that the people of earth 2 had the same
mirrored life as that of our earth until
it became visible to our planet
four years ago after the event people's
lives changed slightly changing their
course of action and perhaps their
future rhoda now believes that her mere
self on the other planet might not have
caused the accident she rushes to john's
house with the flight ticket but he
doesn't open the door for her however
rhoda is determined so she sneaks into
his house through the window when he
sees her jon cannot control his hatred
and starts to choke her the two struggle
for a while until he frees her she gets
up and tells him about the theory she
has heard she claims that the accident
might have never happened and his family
could still be alive
rhoda leaves the ticket for him saying
that he could find his wife and son on
earth too
sometime later rhoda has returned to her
normal life after her apology to john
her mental health is much better the
space shuttle is about to take off when
rhoda sees john in an interview it turns
out that he has accepted her offer and
is going to earth too four months after
the first shuttle took off rhoda is
walking home from work when she is
stunned to see herself from earth 2 in
front of her the movie ends as the two
identical rhodas stare at each other
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching